ME CALL ME.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
TONIGHT THE MAN BEHIND THE
CURTAIN, ROBERT MUELLER, SPOKE
FOR SOME TIME.
YOU MIGHT EXPECT HIM TO HAVE A
BOOMING, POWERFUL VOICE AND A
REASSURING PRESENTATION, YOU
WOULD BE DISAPPOINTED.
HE SEEMED AND SOUNDED OLDER THAN
HIS 74 YEARS, ALMOST TIRED AND
EXASPERATED.
AND YET, DETERMINED TO THROW
ELBOWS ON HIS WAY OUT THE DOOR.
>> THE ORDER APPOINTING THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AUTHORIZED US TO
INVESTIGATE ACTIONS THAT COULD
OBSTRUCT THE INVESTIGATION.
IT HAS SET FORTH IN THE REPORT
AFTER THAT INVESTIGATION, IF WE
HAD HAD A CONFIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT CLEARLY DID NOT COMMIT
A CRIME WE WOULD HAVE SAID SO.
>> Laura: AND HOW ONE
STATEMENT FROM MUELLER, THE MAN
WHO WE HEARD WAS A CONSUMMATE
PROFESSIONAL SPEAKS VOLUMES
ABOUT PERHAPS THE TRUE
MOTIVATION BEHIND THIS
INVESTIGATION AND SPEAKS TO
PROSECUTORIAL BIAS AND A SENSE
OF UNPROFESSIONALISM.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS ACCUSING
MUELLER OF PUTTING HIS THUMB ON
THE SCALE SAYING, MUELLER WENT
BEYOND THE CONCLUSION OF HIS
REPORT AND GAVE A POLITICAL GIFT
TO DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS WHO ARE
SEEKING TO INSTITUTE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP BY IMPLYING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT HAVE
COMMITTED OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTIC
JUSTICE.
MUELLER EFFECTIVELY INVITED
DEMOCRATS TO INCLUDE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
AS I SAID IN MY PODCAST TODAY,
THIS KIND OF REMINDED ME OF JIM
COMEY, IF YOU REMEMBER THE FBI
DIRECTORS, HIS ABSURD
NONINDICTMENT-INDICTMENT BACK IN
2013.
>> ALTHOUGH WE DID NOT FIND
EVIDENCE THAT SECRETARY CLINTON
WILL THAT WERE HIDING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, THEY ADMITTED THEY
WERE EXTREMELY CARELESS IN THEIR
HANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
>> Laura: I WATCH THAT WHOLE
THING SEVERAL TIMES TODAY.
AS WITH MUELLER, REMEMBER,
COMEY'S JOB WAS NOT TO OPINE,
HIS JOB AS INVESTIGATOR WAS TO
INVESTIGATE THE CASE AND MERELY
PRESENT HIS FINDINGS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND HIS BOSSES
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
INSTEAD WHAT HE ENDED UP DOING
WAS A MENACE TO TAKE OFF
EVERYONE.
SETTING ASIDE THAT GLARING FACT
THAT HILLARY GOT OFF FOR WHAT
OTHERS WOULD HAVE BEEN JAILED
FOR, COMEY DID ENORMOUS DAMAGE
TO THE INTEGRITY OF THE FBI AND
RULE OF LAW.
>> ALTHOUGH THERE ARE POTENTIAL
VIOLATIONS OF THE STATUTE
REGARDING THE HANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, OUR
JUDGMENT IS THAT NO REASONABLE
PROSECUTOR WOULD BRING SUCH A
CASE.
>> Laura: THERE'S NOTHING
REASONABLE ABOUT A SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE WHERE AT LEAST HALF THE
COUNTRY THINKS THE ENTIRE THING
IS.
THE DEEP STATE THAT CANDIDATE
TRUMP UP AFTER IT BECAME OBVIOUS
THAT HE WAS GOING TO WIN THE
NOMINATION BECAUSE THEY WERE
TERRIFIED OF EVEN THE REMOTE
PROSPECT OF AN OUTSIDER BECOMING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
EXONERATING MRS. CLINTON WAS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP TO STOPPING
TRUMP, BUT IT DIDN'T WORK.
ONCE TRUMP WON THE PRESIDENCY,
THEY HAD TO FIRE UP THE RUSSIAN
COLLISION INVESTIGATION VIA THE
PHONE HE DOSSIER, THE FISA
COURT, AND OF COURSE, AGENT
MULLER HALPIN COMIC HELPING
ALONG THE WAY.
WHEN THAT DIDN'T WORK, AFTER A
TWO-YEAR LONG INVESTIGATION THEY
FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
AND FAILED TO GET THE
OBSTRUCTION GOODS ON TRUMP.
BUT NOW, MUELLER COMES ALONG IN
HIS FINAL BOW AND IS ATTEMPTING
TO RESUSCITATE THE CORPSE THAT
WAS HIS REPORT.
BUT FOR YOU LITTLE PEOPLE BY THE
WAY, HE'S GOING TO SAY NOTHING
MORE.
>> ANY TESTIMONY FROM THIS
OFFICE WOULD NOT GO BEYOND OUR
REPORT, AND THE REPORT IS MY
TESTIMONY AND FOR THAT REASON I
WILL NOT BE TAKING QUESTIONS
TODAY AS WELL.
>> Laura: THAT'S IT, NO
QUESTIONS.
AFTER COMPLETING THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS NEITHER COMEY NOR
A MUELLER NEEDS TO APPEAR BEFORE
THE CAMERA.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT TODAY
AND DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT BACK
IN JULY OF 2016.
SO WHY DID THEY?
IT WASN'T BECAUSE OF HIS FEIGNED
CONCERN FOR TRANSPARENCY OR
BECAUSE MUELLER WAS CLOSING UP
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE AND
LEAVING FOR THE LAST TIME.
THINKING ABOUT IT TODAY, IT WAS
ALL CURRENTLY TO THE OLD SIN OF
PRIDE.
WE ALL SUFFER FROM IT.
BUT HERE'S A CONCERN FOR WHAT
THEY BOTH HAD IN THEIR PLACE IN
HISTORY.
BOTH MEN ARE LIFELONG PRODUCTS
OF THE WASHINGTON LEGAL
ESTABLISHMENT THAT, AT ITS CORE
REVILED A MAN SUCH AS TRUMP.
TO BE DEFEATED OR EVEN
EMBARRASSED BY A MAN WHO THEY
BELIEVED IS AS UNCOUTH AND
UNDIGNIFIED AS TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS?
THAT'S UNTHINKABLE.
COMEY TURNED HIMSELF IN THE LAW
INTO A PRETZEL TO GIVE HILLARY A
PASS, THEN USED THE COLLUSION
THAT LED TO THE APPOINTMENT OF
MUELLER.
TODAY, MUELLER TRIED TO TURN A
LACK OF EVIDENCE ON OBSTRUCTION
INTO GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHING A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
IT IS WILD.
BOTH OF THEM ARE TRYING TO GET
BACK INTO THE GOOD GRACES OF THE